it wasn't too long after I watched the
video that you did on discrete cosine
transform me and I was thinking about
how music has patterns in it and of
course life imitates those patterns you
get them with number sequences within
flowers and stuff like that and I was
thinking about how a really nice picture
how that could be translated to a piece
of music and whether there was any kind
of like correspondence between the
patterns within a picture and the
patterns within music it was one of
those moments late at night where I just
sat down and I thought let's just do
something you know that's that's the
great thing about programming is you can
just sit there and go let's see what
happens I had this idea that you could
turn pictures sort of standard bitmaps
or JPEGs or whatever into music and I
didn't quite know how I was going to do
it with her I was going to use chords or
get it to produce chords and different
multi-layer instruments or just a single
tune so I think what I did is I'll just
just went straight in for it I thought
I'll get a picture and I'll see what I
can do with it excuse my drawing so if
this is the picture and I'm sure you
know it's separated into a grid of
pixels I started in the top left with
the first pixel and numbered them on the
way down so they work their way down the
column and then it would go back up to
the top there and that would be the
seventh one that would be the eighth one
that'd be the ninth one and so on so in
each pixel you've got the red the green
and the blue and then what I'm going to
call L which is like the luminosity how
bright it is and by using those four
things I decided what sound I wanted to
get out of it basically so I generate a
wave based on the information that I got
from that pixel so the red component was
the length of the note so if that pixel
there had a lot of red in it it would be
a really long note and if it had no red
in it it would be really really tiny no
I didn't let it go to zero smallest it
could be I believe was 250 fifth of a
quarter of a second which is
again arbitrary amounts I was just
making this up I mean it really was
there was no there's no science to it as
such I was just thinking I wonder if I
multiply the blue by this and did
whatever in it and it ended up sounding
nice so the green channel was the octave
it was in a standard concert pitch ie
note the note a is 440 Hertz the octave
below it is 220 Hertz the octave below
that is 110 Hertz so you have it or you
double it each time so it's a
logarithmic scale it's not
straightforward so that that decided the
octave and the balloon decided the note
within the octave each octave has 12
notes and then there's several octaves
so if you get a let's say an AE one the
octave up from that would be the a2 and
then the a sharp one the octave up from
that will be a sharp two but there will
always be 12 notes in each octave so
with these three values that the red
green and blue values which you can get
from a pixel I got the length the octave
and which note within the octave I was
going to use and then the last thing is
the luminosity which is how bright
something is now I think you've covered
this in another video you can sort of
get a level and say that Green is twice
the brightness of red and blue so you
kind of have the green value and you get
what you call it perceived brightness
level of it and that said to me how loud
the note was so something very dark
would be very quiet or the other way
around or something very very dark would
not have a huge amount of red green or
blue so it'll be a very very low note
with very little length and very little
loudness it's almost like it might not
be there which and the brighter the
picture the the longer the whole thing
becomes you get more length on the note
you get higher notes you get more
variation in the tones between them and
it becomes a lot louder the only thing I
did then was I wrote something which
then took that note and fixed it to a
scale so I wanted to so this is to do
with this is how to do with making it
sound musical you know sometimes you've
got 12 notes of the scale and sometimes
you put those two notes next to each
other and they sound quite horrible so I
wanted to limit it to sort of seven
notes which made it a major scale or a
minus
it's a bit like they do with vocals with
on searching someone sings out of tune
and then it moves it to the nearest name
and so after after because I'm assuming
if you hadn't have done that then it
could have sounded like a chimpanzee
forming on a piano it would have sounded
interesting I'm sure but I limited it I
mean I did that afterwards I produce
some stuff and just thought I'll have a
listen through to that and it didn't
sound as nice as if I restricted the
restricted the scale down a little bit
so that was almost like a sidechain I'll
produce the frequency and then I just
sent it off to a function which did
something and then brought it back and I
could change that function depending on
what vibe I wanted in the music and that
was that was something which I haven't
put on the website I put all the code
for this on my website with the
exception of that bit because I thought
that's more down to the person that's
composing the piece of music you know
you can limit the scale and decide what
what you want and what you don't want
based on your own choices you know I've
done 90% of the work but so I ran
through I picked them some photos on my
original pixel Noise music I did it with
six photos
for this one here I thought the first
thing to do let's grab the computer file
logo and run that through the first
thing I did was shrink it down to a
smaller image because a big image can
produce quite a long file I mean
something which is maybe 90 pixels by 50
pixels if it's quite bright or producing
1112 minute wav file and yeah 11 12
minutes of something going blue like
that can be a little bit dull this is a
classic example of what I was talking
about earlier where you don't get much
data as you can see here there's a lot
of black pixels and then there's only
really one color coming through although
there are shade little bits of red and
little bits of blue in there so it
wasn't going to produce anything which
sounded particularly Musical in the same
way that you discuss that JPEG
compression works better on natural
images and not on text and stuff like
that the same is true with this it
produces better results from photos
things that actually take a look I've
got a natural shading or whatever then
something that's a piece of text that
scissors that's not a touch not nature
anyway it's not naturally way so let me
play you the result for that if I
minimize this for a second it is going
down and getting almost no data from the
first column almost no data from the
second column by the time it gets here
you tiny little bit there and then it
goes across there and makes a noise it
goes across there and then you start
getting to little bits to little bits
next to each other and then you've got
the same here and then you've got longer
bit so they're two bits with the gap in
between and then of course the same
reverse out is very clearly in three
sections and you can see the first bit
with the bracket you can see goes there
and then as it gets into the the two
lines that you can see it having a
having two bits of waves and then the C
is there and then this one here is
effectively a reverse of that one so
this wave does quite nicely show the
computer file logo but it's not that
musical so that moved me on to my first
computer which was a taken electron and
I ran this through because it's quite
right it produced a lot nicer result
when you get to the keyboard Mike
Sandler makes more interesting toon do
you know what it reminds me of we did a
sorting with music and graphics yes
video on an acorn machine was on an
Archimedean comedic I've got an
Archimedes a 3000 upstairs these are the
color things that went on board I sit
there at night I won on eBay fast 16
pounds I've got over a three thousand
never plugged it in Wilson what am I
going to do with it so we're still
hearing tons here so how then do you
turn that into so say something maybe a
bit more musical what what we've been
doing okay I've got down here on the
floor a whole load of guitar pedals that
most of the time I use for playing
guitar but I've put some delay on it if
you don't know what delay is it's like
an echo you know when you shout someone
you hello and it comes back yes hello
like that new here it bounced around
well you can artificially put that on
thing so it repeats itself and sounds a
lot bigger and you can put reverb on
things to make it sound like it's in a
big chamber and of course you can
distort things and one of the fun things
about using things like valve amps and
pedals is whatever is the amount of
distortion you can put on stuff and
distorted guitar so that's when it
sounds fuzzy right fuzzy it just makes
it sound sound more more rock and so all
those big guitar solos that you know
from from all the classic rock tunes are
all really really distorted a lot of the
time so if I play you what this electron
picture sounds like with distortion and
delay on
if I skip it on a bit I've just put in
some drum loops
so then you can start just improvising
over the top
I know out of the original 40th minute
piece of music there's a few moments in
it that I think could be turned into
quite nice songs and I probably will
extract those moments I won't keep it
true to using the whole picture I'll
just take out the little melodies I like
from the generated wave and then I'll
loop them around and make songs out of
them so I think from that point of view
it was valid to do to go through the
whole thing to lift something that might
make two songs now if you were Coldplay
for example and you were spending a year
doing an album considering I did this in
a couple of evenings a you know to
produce a 40 minute piece of music that
might inspire two songs is really not
that you know it's not that crazy to do
you know Pink Floyd spent years it was
well not years but months and months in
this year recording household objects
you have pinging elastic bands and stuff
like that trying to get some inspiration
for the album that eventually became
wish you were here so some people got it
and wow this is amazing but the people
who didn't like it tend to put it on and
listen to the first minute or two and go
this sounds like nonsense to me
and then turn it off and I'd say I mean
it's no different to a bit of software
if you download a bit of software and
try it and you can't get your head
around it within two minutes and you
just go out that's rubbish I'll throw it
away and I understand most people don't
have 40 minutes sparing their day to sit
and listen through to a load of Cinthia
nonsense live produce and I don't expect
them to but some people do you know and
that's that's the joy of creating
something that is attempting to be brand
new is that you know it will get them
someone retweets it someone else going
of course this in itself you've picked
up me and we're doing this and someone
else might listen to it and you know it
might get 500 plays it might get 5,000
plays one day who knows I mean it's not
that's it really so the number of slices
per second that it does is the sample
frequency and obviously the more of
those you put in per second